[音楽]
底の穴か
あなたは何からできていますか
あなたはどうですか
多くの人は
細胞
と答えるでしょ
でもあるにそれは正しいかもしれませんか
間違っているかもしれません
細胞の数よりずっと多くのものか
あなたと一緒にいるといったら
えっ
と驚くことでしょう
その一緒に居るというものが
微生物です
人の寒暖はおよそを60兆個の細胞からできていると言われていますがそれより
ずーっと多い数の微生物が県と一緒に住んでいます
なので
そこにいるあなたはああ
細胞からできているのかそれとも微生物の集合体なのか
よくわからないほどです
ひとりぼっちの時も
百町匹のお友達が
一緒だなんて
もう寂しくないですよね
目には見えない微生物ここに揚げてあるのはぜーんぶ
微生物です
なじみのあるものやないものがあると思いますが
微生物と人間の間には切っても切れない関係があります
ここを三河の家というのは古くから
杖道産業がとても盛んな地域です
酒みそしょうゆみりん酢はもちろんのこと
豆3層とかたまり醤油
白周囲など他の地域ではほとんど見られないような黄色品もたくさん作られています
普段は
微生物のことをば意識することが少ないと思いますが
身の回りは微生物では売れています
人ひとりの体の中に100兆個の微生物が着るというわけですから
地球全体で考えるとそれはそれは天文学的な数字になるんですね
微生物学研究の権威である坂口謹一郎先生はかせてこう言いました
微生物に頼んで裏切られたことはない
これは無数に存在する微生物が何らかの形で我々の額に応えてくれる
我々の課題にを解決してくる
まあそういう意味だと私は思っております
実際に
多くの微生物が私の期待に応えてくれて20年以上にもわたる私の研究生活を支えて
くるといいます
例えば
この酵母という微生物ですが
美味しいお酒を作ってくれる微生物として10名です
およそ10年ほど前
大学ブランドのお酒を作ろうということになって
いろいろな花から工房ですね
探し始めました
鼻から穂先ができるだってオシャレていいと思いませんか
綺麗な花に願いをかけて
いろいろな花から微生物をさらし工房探し始めました
花を摘んできて培養液に入れてへ
微生物を増やしてその中から公募探し出していきます
この作業を繰り返すこと約200種類の花を繰り返し繰り返し
頑張って探しました
そしてようやく
取れたのが赤いカーネーションだったんです
このカーネーションからといった酵母を使ってお酒を作ってみました
このお酒ですが
とても甘酸っぱくて美味しいお酒ができました
女子学生にとても人気でした
やっぱり
微生物は公募は私は裏切りませんでした
公募と同様にこの発酵に関係する微生物として
麹菌というのがあります
この麹菌ですが
国の金と呼ばれるほど日本の醸造には欠かせない微生物になっています
日本人は約1千年にもかかってこのコウジ菌を発酵に適したような醸造に適したように
貝殻してきました
私はこの麹菌の可能性に今注目しています
麹菌というのはカビの一種ですですけれどもこのカビの一種
麹菌はとても食欲が旺盛で
いろんなものを食べます非常に食いしん坊です
先ほどお話した酵母は
花の中から取れたくらいですから花の蜜とか果物の塔などしか食べませんとっても
グルメなんですね
それに比べて麹菌は全く違います
何でも食べてくれます雑食なんですね私と一緒です
食べるといっても口があるわけではありません
食べたいものに応じて構想を出します
その酵素によって分解して小さくしてその
の小さくしたものを吸収してように帰っています
では
どうして
この麹菌は
その食べ物
の違いを知りでそのそれに合ったコースを作るのか
とても不思議じゃありませんか
実は麹菌というのは
酵素の設計図をたくさん持っていて体の中に設計図を遺伝子の形で蓄えているのです
私たち日本の研究者が中心となりましてこの麹菌の
すべての遺伝情報を解読しました
これは
その一部ですが色々な酵素の設計図が
この麹菌の良い遺伝子の中に含まれているということが分かりました
たくさんあるということはわかったんですがそれと同時に
よくわからないような遺伝子
設計図もたくさんあるということも分かりました
麹菌がどうやってそうに分けてそれに適したコースを作り出すのか
この仕組みがわかれば我々は麹菌に意のままに酵素を作らせて
それによって人間の役に立つような物質を10入れることができます
の小さな小さな
麹菌ですがとても大きな可能性を秘めているのです
そこであたしたちはこの麹菌にマンナンという物質を食べさせてみました
万なんていうのは
植物の多くに含まれている食物繊維の一つです
例えば漫談が腹膜たくさん含まれているような
木くずとか
食品の野菜のゴミ食品のゴミなどを
麹菌食べさせるとそれを分解する酵素を出してそれらを糖に変えてくれます
ゴミが糖に変わるのですということはゴミだって食べられるということになります
の実を食べるたなんて
と思うかもしれませんがは例えば家畜の飼料に加えることもできますね
なので
我々はそのお肉を
ありがたくいただくことができます
そのようにして
ものを得ることができますが例えばその十
別の日西武戦た別するとプラスチックを作ることもできます
また
それを油とかアルコールに書いて燃料にすることができます
それから例えば
抗生物質とか抗がん剤などの薬だって作ることのできるんです
すごくないですか
このような期待に胸を膨らませて私たちは
マンナンという物質を講じ機に食べさせてみたのです
しかし
予想もしない事が起きました
麹菌が
小さくてよくわからないたんぱく質を大量に作っていたのです
私たちはそのタンパク質がないなのか調べるために
たくさん実況してみました
でも手がかりがつかめないまま時間が過ぎ用としていました
信頼していた麹菌が
私を裏切ろうとして例えば
不安がよぎりました
まあこのような実験をする時に調べたいタンパク質に小さな女鶴子をつけておくのが
普通ですがあるときこの目印を外してみようということになりました
その時ですそのよくわからなかったたんぱく質が酵素として働き始めました
見事にマンな分解し始めたのです
麹菌から
新しいタイプの酵素が見つかった発見された瞬間でした
まだ麹菌にはそんなに面白い酵素が残っていたのかと
学会でも注目を集めました
麹菌はやっぱり私を裏切っていませんでした
その酵素は小さくて熱にも強くて普通のコースとずいぶん性質が違っていました
その新型コースを使うと例えば高齢者のために
野菜などの食べ物を柔らかくして飲み込みやすく消化をよくすることができます
例えば
そのマンナンが分解された
オリゴ糖ができるのですがそれは腸の中に衣類善玉菌の
政府にもとてもプラスになります夢はどんどん広がります
このように千年にもわたって慣れ親しんできた
航時機にもまだまだ多くの可能性が秘められています
我々は
その可能性をどんどん
追求していきたいと思っているんですが
麹菌というのはたった五種類の微生物です
しかしながら我々人間が現在
取り出して
培養して調べることができる微生物は
生物全体の買った1%
またそれ以下であるということが知られています
小さいけれども
非常に影響力を持つこの微生物のこと私たちはほとんど何も知らないといってもいい
いいわけです
しかしながら
裏を返せば
微生物にはまだ100倍以上持つ可能性が残っているということを意味しています
私たちはこの微生物のことをもっともっと研究する必要があると思っています
超からあなたもあなたにくっついている微生物のことを意識してみてください
その微生物たちの可能性をもっと知ることはとても大事です
地球環境等
人間の生活がうまく調和していくためには私たちは微生物のことをもっと知らなければ
いけません
微生物の持っている潜在能力を引き出すことによって
ますますあ
より良い社会を生み出していくことができると考えています
今
もしあなたが誰か
衣食住や
植樹などの3泊まりの問題とか
地球環境とか
エネルギー問題とか
今解決知るしなければならない課題を抱えていたとして
今すぐ微生物の研究を始めれば
いつか近い将来にその課題は対決されるといってもあながち間違いではありません
微生物の頼んで裏切られたことはない
あなたも一つ
何かを頼めませんか
ありがとうございました